what an incredible stroke of luck a
helpless waif and fishnet tights and
go-go boots
Oh boom ha ha oh I think pretty much all
of America had a crush on Winnie Cooper
ray absolutely I think you're right you
know how perfect was Danica McKellar in
the Wonder Years that first episode
aired nearly 30 years ago
Oh dad me too now she's back in a new TV
movie but wherever Danica goes you know
winning is sure to follow
do you guys mind if I sit with you
honey can I hear what would you do here
when I walk into a restaurant because
I'll start playing
just for me what would you do if I sang
out of tune now 41 Danica has barely
changed could you ever do me a solid and
have a wonder years reunion press I
would just said he would never do that a
year like a reunion arena
no no none maybe he'll change his mind
meanwhile Danika stars in the new
Hallmark Channel movie wedding bells as
a bridesmaid who falls for a best man I
do I do in real life the PhD in
mathematics had her own fairytale
wedding to attorneys Scots Fez Loski in
2014 I got a second date I told my best
friend if he asked me to marry him I'd
say yes Scott and I got married in Kauai
and we did a sunrise wedding Oh like I
was walking down the aisle at 6:30 in
the morning just as the Sun was coming
up it was so beautiful
her son Draco from her first marriage
was part of the ceremony and her cake
was a three-tiered confection to
celebrate her new role Jane Lockhart at
sweet lady Jane in Santa Monica set up a
little wedding cake tasting yeah we have
red velvet oh yes here's what I like you
can taste the cream cheese can you say
died and gone to heaven
I fell in love with coconut but that
triple bears ode to my future husband
this is gonna be our cake